alors imaginez un peu la scène vous avez
une une salle de classe des élèves de
seconde qui suivent un cours d'espagnol
le cours a lieu de 9h à 10h la
professeur s'appelle madame Lassalle
elle a une cinquantaine d'années elle
est globalement assez appréciée par les
élèves elle est plutôt charismatique
dynamique et elle est depuis longtemps
dans cette école qui est très bien
réputée sur la côte basque avec aucun
problème particulier ni de délinquance
ni de stupéfiant donc on est dans cette
salle de classe il est le cours touche à
sa fin il y aurait alentours de 9h45 et
là un drame absolu un élève se saisit du
couteau qui est dans son sac se dirige
vers une des portes de la salle de
classe la verrouille puis marche vers sa
professeur et lui assène au moins un
coup de couteau au thorax alors là dans
la salle de classe ce qu'on nous
rapporte c'est que c'est la stupé la
stupéfaction tout le monde est sidéré
certains élèves ont peut-être même pas
vu ce qui s'était passé parce que ça se
passe assez rapidement finalement
et puis tout d'un coup la panique
[Musique]
pour comprendre sa personnalité et ce
qu'ils disent il y a trois adjectifs qui
reviennent celui de solitaire de bizarre
et celui de fragile alors maintenant la
question qui se pose quand on connaît sa
personnalité les fesses et qu'est-ce qui
a amené cet élève à commettre
l'irréparable alors là sur le mobile
c'est comme ça qu'on dit en termes
policier on sait que cet élève il a dit
aux policiers qu'il a des armes aux
professeur pendant qu'il a désarmé il a
dit je suis possédé et j'ai rêvé il a
dit qu'il avait rêvé la nuit précédente
enfin il avait entendu une voix pardon
qui lui avait dit de tuer sa professeur
d'espagnol donc est-ce dire qu'il est
fou et se dire qu'il a des problèmes
psychiatriques qu'il a peut-être
consommé des médicaments de la drogue ça
ce sera bien sûr aux expertises aux
enquêteurs de l'Éternel en tous les cas
le parquet de Bayonne a estimé que son
état physique et mental était compatible
avec une mesure de garde à vue pour être
interrogée par les policiers merci à
morue beaucoup un journaliste sur cnews
on a marié Estelle Dupont avec nous
psychologue clinicienne
entendent des voix est-ce que c'est
possible en psychiatrie est-ce que voilà
c'est ce qu'on peut voilà c'est quoi
c'est de la schizophrénie c'est quoi
c'est ma première pensée va à la famille
de la victime bien évidemment et puis à
tous les adolescents qui ont assisté à
ce drame effroyable alors la première
hypothèse évidemment qu'on peut faire
dans la mesure où il a 16 ans ou il n'y
a pas d'antécédent de psychiatrique mais
des qualificatifs qui devront être
vérifiées dans l'examen clinique de
bizarre et de solitaire des
hallucinations auditives et puis une
tout d'un coup un passage à l'acte
extrêmement violent dont il dira après
coup qu'il est possédé c'est évidemment
une bouffée délirante qui serait
peut-être la porte d'entrée dans une
schizophrénie qui n'a pas encore été
décompensée puisque en général la
schizophrénie est une pathologie
psychiatrique qu'on dès qu'on pense à
peu près entre 17 et 20 ans donc ça
c'est la première hypothèse et c'est
bouffer délirante se font parfois la
faveur d'une prise de cannabis mais pas
toujours on n'est pas tous pareils face
au THC on n'est pas tous égaux et chez
certains ça déclenche des bouffées
délirantes maintenant il faut savoir
qu'il y a à peu près 1% dans la
population de schizophrène et c'est un
chiffre très stable à peu près partout
dans le monde en revanche il y a 10% de
la population générale qui entendra un
jour ou l'autre dans sa vie des voix
d'accord sans jamais présenter un profil
psychotique donc c'est pas parce que un
jour on a entendu une voix qu'on est
psychotique inversement c'est pas parce
que on est psychotique et qu'on entend
une voix qu'on passe à l'acte de manière
violente et on ne peut pas toujours
s'expliquer ou se consoler de la
violence par une explication
psychiatrique de psychose parce que ça
ne se ça ne se positionne pas de cette
manière il y a aussi des gens très bien
qui sont pas du tout psychotiques il y a
une autre hypothèse qui est possible
c'est celle d'un trouble dissociatif
c'est à dire que ce jeune bon ce jeune
homme semble quand même présenter des
traits psychotiques importants comme le
repli sur soi etc mais il faut aussi
explorer la piste ce qui sera fait par
l'expert psychiatrique d'un trouble
dissociatif c'est à dire que parfois la
personne quand elle a vécu un choc
traumatique il y a très longtemps ce
choc traumatique est mis de côté il est
coupé du reste de la personnalité ça lui
permet de continuer à fonctionner
normalement sauf que cette partie qui
est dissociée un jour on sait pas
pourquoi elle pilote elle prend les
commandes et c'est là qu'on peut
expliquer le terme de je suis possédé
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a quelque chose qui
refait surface qui n'a pas été intégré
exprimé élaboré conscientiser et qui va
venir prendre les commandes et on se
trouve avec des jeunes aujourd'hui il y
a pas plus de schizophrène qu'avant par
contre il y a plus de troubles
dissociatifs avec des passages actes
très violents
pour de nombreuses raisons mais
notamment le fait que l'appauvrissement
du langage et la l'excessive
consommation d'écran fait que la limite
entre le réel et l'imaginaire est très
fragile et que parfois les jeunes sont
un peu dans un état hypnotique à force
d'avoir passé des heures sur les écrans
et n'arrive plus en fait à faire appel à
un surmoi avec des interdits qui leur
permet de s'empêcher de passer à l'acte
sur eux-mêmes ou sur autrui très
intéressant
on a eu un élève de la professeur qui
souhaitait témoigner ce soir de ce qu'il
avait vécu il était en cours lorsque
l'effet ont eu lieu et au départ on leur
a demandé de rester en classe pour un
exercice de sécurité écoutez
en fait on était en cours d'histoire on
voulait déjà de cours
dans leur création mais lorsque nous
étions prêt à partir mais en fait il y a
une surveillance qui vient nous dire que
on avait soi-disant un exercice
on devait rester dans la classe il y
avait des certaines rumeurs qui
commençait à tourner on a un élève dans
la classe sa prof sa mère et professeur
que
le professeur
de bonheur des
élèves ont ensuite été confinés
plusieurs heures alors salle de classe
avant de pouvoir rentrer chez eux dans
des conditions très particulières
dans la classe donc de 10h à midi mais
sans sans qu'on puisse sortir en fait il
y a une des trois CPE donc la CTS
collège 4e 3e qui est venu à la classe
et qui
nous a dit de faire un détour
[Applaudissements]
quelqu'un que tout le monde décrit comme
une professeur incroyable et très à
l'écouter
espagnol il a
un très bon professeur
tu te souviens de nos problèmes et de
notification
alors Mathis qui est avec nous toi tu es
un ancien élève de cette professeur
d'espagnol qui a été assassiné ce matin
et quand tu as appris la nouvelle
ça a été un choc parce que nous à
Saint-Jean-de-Luz à saint Thomas on
n'avait jamais eu de choses comme ça qui
s'était passé on n'a jamais vécu
d'événements comme ça et donc moi je
l'ai appris par l'intermédiaire de mon
frère qui était en cours et donc
il m'a dit que la classe était
exactement comme le témoignage c'est à
dire qu'on qui sont venus on leur a dit
il t'a raconté le et il m'a envoyé un
message pour me dire ce qui se passait à
peu près et donc moi je suis venu tout
de suite en bas de saint Thomas au
parking et c'est là qu'on a vu les
militaires la police on a vu tous les
deux enfin j'ai vu tous les parents
d'élèves aussi qui étaient rassemblés et
forcément on n'avait pas le droit
d'entrer personne de sortir donc après
l'attente a été très longue mais
quand les élèves sont sortis il y en
avait plein d'élèves en pleurs d'autres
qui tremblaient et ça a dû être vraiment
terrible pour ceux qui étaient en classe
avec elle même pour tous les autres
qu'il avait au quotidien parce que c'est
vrai que c'est un lycée très très
tranquille voilà en principe oui on a
jamais eu de choses moi pendant mes
années j'ai fait collègues il sait
là-bas on n'a jamais eu aucun événement
de ce style tout allait bien enfin les
profs étaient sympathiques leur but est
de nous emmener vers le haut de nous
faire réussir donc on n'a jamais eu de
gros problèmes avec eux ou c'est cadeau
très chic là-bas
et soit on pense forcément à cette
professeur et à ses proches et toi tu as
eu cette professeur quand tu étais en
troisième en quatrième d'accord et
c'était une prof passionnée elle aimait
son boulot elle voulait tout faire pour
qu'on réussisse elle était pas très
sévère elle était pas très autoritaire
avec nous elle était vraiment une prof
idéale quoi enfin je sais pas si ça se
dit mais vraiment une très bonne prof et
c'est celle qu'on voulait avoir quoi en
quelque sorte c'est vraiment
j'ai que des très bons souvenirs à
laquelle et voilà on n'oubliera jamais
alors les élèves bien sûr sont très très
choqués on a écouté un dernier sonore de
de cet élève qui n'a pas eu accès à une
cellule psychologique il est très très
marqué
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a pas eu du cellule c'est plus
vraiment pour ceux qui étaient à l'étage
et les Clash royale pour l'instant c'est
rien mais je pense sûrement que demain
matin on aura des gens qui vont venir
nous parler ça ça sûrement une cellule
c'est pour tout le monde je pense quand
même je trouve normal qu'on doit prendre
du temps avant de pouvoir comprendre
alors Marie Estelle il y a énormément de
gens qui réagissent à ce que vous avez
dit il y a un instant parce que c'est
vrai que c'est pas la première fois dans
cette émission qu'on entend
un drame et derrière quelqu'un qui dit
j'ai entendu une voix me dire de faire
ça de faire ci et c'est vrai que ça ça
peut vraiment choquer et téléspectateurs
de se dire on peut tous est-ce qu'on
peut tous Voilà entendre un moment des
voix oui
Estelle ce matin il y a un psychiatre
qui disait personne ne passe à un tel
acte sans qu'il ait eu au moins un an
des signes qui commençaient à montrer
que ce garçon arrivait déjà dans le
délire et tout ça ça vient pas du jour
au lendemain ça veut dire que depuis un
an j'imagine ses parents ou les
professeurs ou il était pas suivi
personne a marqué non il était pas suivi
et c'était quand on fait bien l'examen
on peut dire il y a pas d'antécédent
c'est à dire il y a rien eu de noter
dans le dossier médical il y a pas eu de
passage à l'acte avant le premier
évidemment mais quand on regarde un peu
finement il y a toujours des signes
précurseurs et notamment chez les
schizophrènes dans la petite enfance
c'est à dire que vers trois quatre le
contact avec l'enfant la socialisation
se fait un peu difficilement là il y
avait du repli il y en a un qui le
décrit comme bizarre c'est vraiment
l'adjectif qui vient à tout un chacun
face à quelqu'un qui est dissocié ou qui
est schizophrène donc donc voilà alors
est-ce que ça peut tous nous arriver
encore une fois on va être 10 % dans la
population en temps des voix on sera pas
10 % à passer à l'acte et un tas de gens
n'entendent pas de voix et passer à
l'acte donc ça il faut pas le il faut
pas le prendre comme ça dans le passage
à l'axe schizophrène c'est vrai que
classiquement c'est un homme qui est sur
une rame de métro il entend une voix qui
lui dit cette femme et Satan il faut la
tuer et il la pousse sous la sous les
roues du métro ça c'est typiquement le
crime schizophrène mais encore une fois
c'est 1% la population donc
rassurez-vous c'est pas la maladie
mentale ça n'est pas contagieux ça n'est
pas ça n'est pas ce qui est très
important c'est le diagnostic et pour
voir les signes précurseurs il faut
qu'on s'occupe de nos enfants c'est à
dire faut qu'il y ait des psychologues
scolaires faut qu'il y ait des
infirmiers faut qu'il y ait des parents
qui mettent pas l'enfant devant la
télévision faut qu'on les regarde faut
qu'on leur parle parce que en fait on
voit un les enfants qui est dans
l'imaginaire du jeu ou qui est dans un
imaginaire bizarre si on s'y intéresse
on s'en rend compte un ado qui a des
propos d'ados quand rien intéresse et
qui envoie tout balader c'est pas pareil
qu'un ado qui commence à être incohérent
vous voyez et il faut se faire confiance
mais pour avoir des signes il faut
regarder nos enfants et si on les
regarde on aura des signes évidemment
précurseurs mais aujourd'hui avec la
crise sanitaire parce que quand même les
chiffres de la violence ont augmenté
parallèlement avec les mesures
sanitaires avec les chiffres de
décompensation chez les jeunes on a tous
nous les professionnels de la
psychologie six mois d'attendre dans nos
cabinets parce que ils vont mal mais le
diagnostic il sera posé dans 6 mois
la piste des troubles psychiatriques
faut quand même la prendre avec des
pincettes ça ne se base que ça rapide
déclaration du suspect moi je j'ai
changé avec des policiers et des
magistrats et ce qui me disait aussi
c'est que vous avez des personnes qui
passent à l'acte parfois de manière
pulsionnelle qui vont par exemple porter
des coups de couteau qui n'explique pas
leurs gestes et donc qui disent ben en
fait je suis possédé j'entends des voix
parce qu'en fait il préfère se
déresponsabiliser voilà exactement la
pièce qui vient en premier lieu quand on
entend hallucination on entend ce
schizophrénie mais encore une fois c'est
pas parce qu'il y a une voix qui a une
schizophrénie la deuxième piste c'est le
trouble dissociatif ou la personne se
sent possédée d'un coup c'est à dire
qu'une partie d'elle-même clivée prend
le contrôle et puis la troisième
hypothèse c'est aussi quelqu'un qui
vient expliquer un geste qui est
inexplicable et qui est impardonnable en
disant c'est pas de ma faute j'ai
entendu une voix c'est mais ça il y a
que l'examen psychiatrique et pas moi
ici qui ne l'ai pas vu qui pourrait le
déterminer eu des soucis entre cet élève
et la professeur avant ou pas du tout
alors pas notre connaissance ça bien sûr
là les enquêteurs vont essayer de
remonter loin
voilà de passifs de pour le moment il
n'a pas expliqué son geste c'est-à-dire
qu'il est resté vague dans ses propos il
a pas dit il y avait un conflit c'est
collecte de classe qui sont très choqués
qui commencent à être entendu non pas
non plus parler d'un conflit entre eux
ce sera déterminé il faut quand même
dire que s'il a été placé en garde à vue
c'est que il a été jugé qu'il y avait
pas d'altération du discernement il a pu
être entendu et l'enquête est quand même
ouverte pour assassinat c'est-à-dire
meurtre avec préméditation donc
effectivement pour le moment alors c'est
un très bon élève très bon élève avec
mention excellent il était là je crois
depuis septembre voilà brevet parfait
etc très bon élève et puis donc c'est
c'est toi qui l'entend mais pour le
moment pour le moment il est considéré
effectivement comme potentiellement
responsable de ces actes pour les
enquêtes si je peux me permettre en tous
les cas c'est très intéressant ce que
vous disiez sur le psychiatrique parce
que sera un impact énorme sur le
jugement de cette personne si si on
décèle que son jugement était altéré la
peine est divisée par trois et si on
décerne que son jugement était aboli il
est jugé et responsable pénalement et
donc il ne peut pas être jugé et donc à
ce moment-là il est internet d'office